je suis sans voix
j'ai un sentiment d'honneur écrasant
mais aussi
un sens des responsabilités
[Musique]
je suis totalement convaincu
que
vous savez que
la qualité que tout le monde mérite qualité
peu importe que vous soyez pauvre
ou riche et ce sont toutes mes
idées sur la façon dont je peux créer du confort même pour
les plus pauvres
donc si vous reliez cela à la
justice sociale je suis honoré d'entendre cela donc mais
pour moi cela fait partie de mon ADN
[Musique]
donc je voulais étudier une technique que je
peux simplement connecter avec les
connaissances traditionnelles dans mon village natal ou dans mon
pays c'était
un devoir envers mon peuple
vous savez
parce que je voulais contribuer
en tant que membre de cette communauté au
développement de cette communauté
[Musique]
je ne sais pas quelle sera la réaction
en afrique
mais quelque chose est sûr que
nous avons beaucoup de
jeunes qui cherchent vous savez des
opportunités
et puis en voyant
l'un d'eux
que je suis toujours en train de
gagner
le prix prisca
peut-être une grande grande ouverture vous savez peut-être une
grande inspiration
pour devenir architecte vous savez
ouais